bringing you part two of detailed leak
to review that includes leak three pages
as well keep it in mind that most of the
events mentioned in this review have
already been confirmed by either preview
promise or trailers so if you don't want
anything spoil it's time for you to
close this video before I start let me
just highlight that this might be an
early version of the script meaning that
some details might have been changed in
the process yesterday's video or should
I say first half of the fifth episode
ended with a huge meeting in the main
hole in the castle of Dragonstone so far
this meeting resulted with Jon Snow
Dallas and Jordi signing to go on a
mission beyond the wall to catch a fight
in order to prove to Cersei and other
lords of westeros that the danger is
real
however rebels pointed out that any
evidence they'd find will be useless
unless Cersei grants them an audience in
the first place and is somehow prevented
from murdering them all during mentioned
audience Tyrion knows this and has a
proposition Tyrion says let me arrange a
meeting with my brother Jaime the only
person to whom my sister Alison then is
a bit suspicious about as beti reinsures
that that's the only way that was says
he can smuggle Tyrion into King's
Landing before he leaves it John and
others on a mission beyond the wall but
if the gold cloaks recognized the most
famous dwarf in the world
well Davos isn't much of a fighter then
he asks what happens if this whole plan
about convincing Cersei and other Lords
in the night King's existence fails on
the cheater Tyrion or Jon responds with
we hope a hundred thousand that men
don't come to slaughter us until we're
done slaughtering each other all town is
next a tired and frustrated Samuel is
working all night on his punishment
homework Gil is supposedly helping him
and is reading aloud all the details
she's finding in the pages of these
documents asking questions in the
process he finds the personal diary of
High Septon Maynard who held office
during the reign of the Mad King the man
kept notes about every detail of his
life every meal he ate his various
appointments and encounters even moments
important or not
while sam starts questioning why he even
came to the Citadel in the first place
he's questioning his use to Jon Gilly
finds something of the huge importance
Gilly says oh there's something about a
stark Lyanna Stark now Sam is very
intrigued he takes the book from her and
reads Maynard century details that High
Septon was compelled by Crown Prince
Rhaegar the mad king's son and heir to
secretly and now his marriage to Elia
Martell then as the word of the usurper
began he traveled to Dorne to marry rare
currently
in sacred ceremony in the previous
leaked review from some other source
there was stated that Gilley
mispronounced regars name and therefore
Sam didn't even catch this important
detail and didn't find out John's
parentage let's hope this new leaked
review will be more accurate since I
really want Sam to learn Oh Joshua
lineage later Sam is cleaning floor when
a stack of inbox Freeman Scrolls catches
his eye after a few boring letters Sam
sees the letter from interval that was
earlier sent to all parts of the Seven
Kingdoms the army of the Dead is
marching on the wall exactly Sam warned
it would the archmaester said I'll take
the scroll reads and passes it around to
the other masters the Masters doubt in
its accuracy they have read many dire
warnings of this sort
presuming the letter is real the
archmaester asked Sam what he would have
the Masters do Sam is excited finally
these professors are going to listen to
him sam says Westeros chose the Citadel
all the ministers will advise all their
Lords so send their soldiers north to
hold the wall again tonight King while
the Masters here dr. the forbidden tones
for how to defeat him the Irish Minster
is considering Sam's argument the
archmaester however proposes another
scenario to the ministers this letter is
a ploy by the king in the north and the
Dragon Queen to divide the south of
soldiers and make conquest easier Sam
once argued his side further but
archmaester cuts him short and says
thank you for bringing this to our
attention we'll take this into serious
consideration Sam knows he failed as he
is about to leave the arch Minster calls
out to Sam her Targaryen girl burnt your
father live horrible thing horrible
thing where's that book you were getting
for me after hearing masters opinion
regarding the Great War deaths coming
Sen decides to grab as many books and
Scrolls as he can in the restricted area
of the library and decided to leave
Alton for Winterfell on gillis question
if he is sure about leaving and not
becoming maester Sam answers with I'm
tired of reading about the achievements
of better man this is exact lines Sam's
father Randall told him back in the 6th
episode of the previous season
Randall told him your nose is buried in
the books spending your life reading
about the achievements of better men
back in King's Landing bran gets a
little bird from Tyrion Silvia a
Targaryen seal he can't help but smile
happy for Tyrion the red keep looms from
the myths of Blackwater Bay as Davos
guys a small rowboat through the water
Tyrion jokes the last time he was here
he killed his father with
crossbow that was replies little s he
was there Tyrion killed his son with
wildfire but they're on the same side
they pulled a rowboat in a hidden Co
near the entrance to flea bottom with a
red cape looming overhead Tyrion goes to
meet Jaime and Bronn and his surprised
then dowas heads up a set of stairs
asking you're not staying with the boat
that was shakes his head and says he has
his own business to attend to
Tyrion manages to talk Jaime out of
murdering him although everything Tyrion
says may be true for Jaime doesn't
justify siding with the daughter of the
mad king who owns his family death
Tyrion tries to prove him wrong staining
at Dany has three dragons and yet she
has not attacked King's Landing because
unlike her father she is not willing to
kill thousands of innocent people
Tyrion also says that if Cersei had
three dragons and someone else were
sitting on the Iron Throne Cersei would
burn everything down
Jaime is willing to hear out Tyrion they
both know that Cersei will never bend
the knee to anyone but Tyrion briefly
outlines the trouble coming from beyond
the wall
Jaime's skeptical of exterior specs and
says don't worry they'll have proof
Tyrion continues then he wants to deal
with the South first you want her to
deal with the north first Jaime asks
what Aaron's proposing Tyrion smiles and
says glad you asked which is when the
scene switches to a huge Warhammer being
pulled from the forge we hear that was
saying I'd gone to every shop tavern or
brothel and was about to give up now we
see the blacksmith's face ginjury Ginja
shows that was the Warhammer and says
he's been practicing and his guide I'm
pretty good must be some of his father
in him after all that was once know for
which set ginjury intended to fight
ginjuries not sure and says they all
seem pretty horrible that was agrees but
says he's found the least horrible of
them his King might even be a great fan
of ginjury cares to fight for the right
side Genji grabs his hammer and helmet
out a second thought and leaves with
Davos a bit later upon having a trouble
with the gold closed injury kills both
of them at his hammer
well that was in Tyrion watch surprise
from the sidelines the three are then
heading back to Dragonstone in
Winterfell there's a huge meeting
regarding Jon's absence since I shirts
the Lord's the jungler turns soon and
until then she has everything well in
hand few Lords are saying she has done a
fine job as would be expected of Ned
Stark's true born daughter while Jon
Snow followed his brother's course and
took off with a foreign woman Leanna
again calls out Lord saying
a month ago they crammed John and now
they're upset that he is doing his job
or instantly likes this little girl
Glover wants to send a raven demanding
John's immediate return from Dragonstone
which is an aria stands up and says John
is your king and one doesn't make
demands of a king not if one intends to
keep his head a little finger then tries
to make a conflict between the Starks
sisters a bit later Arya full of sand
fights Littlefinger in conference with
the Lord lover and Lord Royce it doesn't
look like a conversation they'd want
public finally Arya Falls Littlefinger
back to his chambers and sees maester
wolkan approach as a little finger is
about to enter and hand him a letter
then Littlefinger leaves his room and as
soon as Littlefinger is out of sight
arya box to the door picks the lock and
sneaks into the room she finds a letter
that her sister wrote in the first
season under the command of Cersei as
Arya is leaving this silly little finger
with his creepy smile confirming it's
all part of his game back to Dragonstone
John is getting ready to go when that
was enters with ginjury that was he told
ginjury not to tell anyone about his
parentage but then ginjury takes a risk
steps forward and says hi I'm Robert
Baratheon's son upon sharing quite an
interesting conversation Ginja
volunteers for the mission and John
accepts it the scenes which is on the
shores of Dragonstone as John Jorah
ginjury double sent some men prepared to
go loading the ship with food the new
dragonglass weapons cold-weather gear
etc there are also few scenes between
dangerous fellows between Danny and John
Singh farewell to each other
then back at King's Landing Cersei
reveals to Jamie - is pregnant or ponder
having a serious conversation regarding
the baby and their brother Tyrion as
well
Cersei doesn't believe the ridiculous
raven they just got from Winterfell
about the army of the Dead Jamie tells
her he met with Tyrion Cersei surprised
him by already knowing about it
and asks him if he really thinks anyone
bearing news can enter this city without
her knowing
Cersei also asks if he really thinks
it's wise to conspire with her enemies
behind her back Jamie gives Cersei a
notes from the meeting which we didn't
hear in the Tyrion scene they can meet
in the dragon pit they will have
home-court advantage then he will not
bring a large amount of troops he says
that Tyrion plans to show absol proof of
the threat beyond the wall and if Circe
is still is not convinced everyone just
resumes the war Jamie is fully prepared
for long tortures fight to persuade
Cersei by
shocks him by quickly agreeing the
episode ends with John leading his group
that contains of girag injury torment
hound Barrack Thoris and a few more
members of the Brotherhood be on the
wall to catch a bite all of them met at
East watch and agreed to go beyond the
wall under John's leadership to help him
on his mission there you have it guys
part two of detailed review for the
fifth episode that seems to be quite
accurate